hello good morning well our first guest
dominated headlines across the UK two
years ago when his battle with the
gunman became over covered became
symbolic of a disconnect between
Westminster and the North and the mayor
of Greater Manchester has campaigned for
greater investment and autonomy for his
region and of course the northern
economy in general the former house
psychos also sometimes touted as a
potential future labor leader well he
joins us now I'm delighted to say the
mayor of the greater Manchester Andy
Burnham thank you very much for being on
the program this morning and it feels
right to start with the budget this week
a pretty extraordinary really ripping up
treasury Orthodoxy and also a big
departure from Boris Johnson's brand of
concern verbatism as well what did you
make of it
yeah
to be honest Sophie I I can still barely
believe what we saw on Friday we're in
the midst of the worst cost of living
crisis we've ever experienced you know
people in this part of the world in
Greater Manchester their heads are
slipping beneath the water they're
living just using their microwave not
using a cooker they've changed their
life dramatically a survey disabled
people in Greater Manchester last week
said that over half have cut back what
they're eating because they can't afford
to eat and then you have a budget that
splurges billions on the wealthiest
people in the country and actually
doesn't do anything meaningful to get
people through the autumn in the winter
so honestly I can barely believe it it's
you know having been through a period of
national Unity the way I would describe
it Friday's budget was a flagrant Act of
vandalism on the social cohesion of this
of this country the government has drawn
battle lines with working people they've
told us which side they're on I think
labor conference now has a chance uh to
to pick up that that battle speak for
ordinary people people and in doing so I
think uh put the government on borrow
time
okay so you say that their dividing
lines have been drawn and labor needs to
use this opportunity at conference so
quite clearly then uh do you think labor
thick should commit to reversing at the
tax cuts if Labor's in government
well personally I would have said this
wasn't a time for tax cuts this was a
time to use what money was there to help
people for instance on benefits there
should have been an uplift to Universal
Credit as we saw I just want to come in
again if I may I just want to come in if
I may because it was a really fun Should
labor commit to reversing the tax cuts
if you're in power
I thought I think I answered it I said
yes this wasn't the time the time for
tax cuts I I think money needs to be in
the system now to help people
but if I may that's not that's not quite
the same I think they should I I'm
saying that they so yes they should
because okay yeah I said that but I said
that in the answer to the first question
I was coming on to say you know we've
got a situation where public sector pay
is nowhere near inflation so we've got a
potential for a wave of industrial
dispute over over the um over the winter
uh fat money should have been used
instead to help people with their pay
packet so they can continue to go to
work for us in the NHS or continue uh to
service on the front line in the fire
service without worrying about what's
going on in their own home that is what
the money should have been used for to
help us through
the cost of living crisis and I think
they've made that I think the
government's made the wrong choice in
this moment and it's left millions of of
people at risk at risk this winter lives
honestly are on the line we'll have a
huge Mental Health crisis if nothing
changes and that should have been the
priority targeted support for people to
to get people through this period rather
than than just giving away billions of
pounds borrowing billions of pounds uh
for bankers and billionaires I mean it's
just obscene it really is obscene and I
would see labor this week come together
kissed arm has put us in a position
where we can win the next election this
is the first conference Sophie since we
left left government where I think it's
odds on that there could be a labor
government within one or two years so
we're in that position and The Time Is
Now not to draw battle lines with
ourselves the government's drawn battle
lines with awesome with ordinary working
people let's unite and take the fight to
them in Liverpool this week
so you're saying there could be a labor
government within one or two years and I
just want to be crystal clear and
forgive me if I you know you obviously
feel that you've answered but I just
want to be crystal clear for myself are
you saying that that labor government in
one or two years that you believe it
will be it should reverse the 1p cut to
income tax and reverse the change to the
45p rate
yes I am saying that because I don't
think it's the most targeted way of
using the resources that we've got at
this moment in time I would use it
though to support people in different
ways so I'm not saying we wouldn't put
money in people's pockets but if you
keep that money you are then able to
Target it for those who most need it
because obviously if you cut the 20p
rate it benefits it benefits not as
targeted a measure as doing other things
such as supporting people who are at
real risk and that those are people on
Universal Credit you've got to sort out
public sector pay you can't leave kind
of millions and millions of people in
the public sector providing providing
Services we all depend upon who who
themselves can't make things add up you
just can't do that that's a recipe for
chaos in our Public Services over the
winter so that that is my position I
don't think it was a time for tax cuts I
think this is a time to support people
through a crisis
um I want to talk a bit more about the
kind of policies that you would also
like to see I I know that you are
planning on bringing the buses back
under at National control uh public
control should say in what in Manchester
and last month you told my colleague Kay
Burley that there's a case to
renationalizing the energy companies as
well is that what you want to do
well it follows on from what I was just
saying Sophie because we've got to a
position in this country where people
can't afford life's Essentials they
can't afford water they can't afford
energy they can't afford gas to cook as
I was saying before and they're just
using a microwave they can't afford to
travel by bus and they certainly can't
afford to travel by train and I think if
you go back to the 80s people warned
about this that if you lose control of
these services in the end the price will
go up I don't think the services
improved to be honest with you and
certainly with rail it's gone massively
backwards and you've got to I would say
have more public control of the basics
so that you can make them affordable to
Ordinary People and it's not just words
because as you say we've done that in
Greater Manchester I have taken the
decision to put buses back under public
control and that comes in a year from
now but in advance of that we've already
brought in a fair cap so that people can
afford to use use the buses and we have
a system of Affairs that is similar to
London so that is what we are we are
doing and I do think it's right to be
able open-minded about more public
control more public ownership so that we
don't leave ourselves so exposed to to
energy costs as we are at this moment in
time
um it's interesting isn't it and there's
a big focus on green energy at this at
conference we'll be talking to Ed
miliband about that a little bit later
as well and the new policy uh saying
that they want to commit to Net Zero
electricity by 2030. given the public
anxiety about bills do you think that's
the right Focus
well if you combine it with what I was
just saying by doing it through more uh
it doesn't have to be National ownership
of course you couldn't Empower bodies
like mine to take a a bigger stake in
the development of of new renewable
energy let me say this this is a good
bold policy from kirst armor and Ed
miliband this morning this is the right
way to go face up to the future rather
than going back to the past with with
fracking which by the way would really
impact on an area like this where I'm
talking to you from now a former mining
area fracking would disproportionately
affect the north of England it's
backward looking but it's also divisive
and that's why I say embrace the future
and Labor's doing that and I think they
need to really explain how this policy
could get people's energy bills down and
make us more energy secure as I'm sure
they'll do at conference this week and
that's exactly the kind of policy that I
think labor should be putting forward as
well as that immediate help for people
through the cost of living crisis
okay we'll be talking to Edmond about
that a bit in a bit more detail later
it's interesting you're talking so using
this as an example of a bold policy and
you've been talking that to be fair
about quite bold policies yourself like
National nationalization for example
more public ownership and being clear on
tax policy as well
we know when there's trusts and quasi
quality stand whatever you think of what
happened on Friday it was a pretty
radical uh budget no one's going to be
left in any doubt about what they stand
for do you think that labor needs to be
I guess a bit Bolder in its approach
this weekend
well let's trust in quasi quaten we're
radical radical but deeply wrong and I
would go so far to say immoral I don't
see how you can possibly justify a
package like that when as I said before
the heads of millions of people are
slipping beneath the water I just don't
understand how you can possibly uh put
that forward uh it's it's Brazen it's
the drawing of battlelands as I say with
ordinary people so this is the time for
labor to to move up and set out an
alternative that people can support and
so I I want to be clear you know I'm
supporting here I want the party to
unite here in Liverpool they've got us
in a position where we've got a clear
and sustained pole lead which is no
small achievement it's a it's a big
achievement and I think the government
has now opened up a huge opportunity for
labor to put out a program that connects
with ordinary people so yes I would say
be bolder uh be clear about what we will
what we will do I'm a little
disappointed to hear the party saying
that it's it's going to rule out um
electoral reform I I think I would say
to them listen to hear the mood of
conference on that particular issue I
hope conference will still vote in favor
of that because we've got to maximize
the chance here of a labor-led
government but I would also just say for
people who doubt the case for for
electoral reform over the summer we have
just seen the most graphic demonstration
we've ever seen of how a small number of
people a small Elite can manipulate the
political system in their interests and
that's what we saw on Friday this was a
budget for Bankers this was a budget for
Tory donors that is what has happened in
this country and this is what labor now
can say to the public look we're going
to change things we're going to reform
the way votes work we're going to reform
the way politics works and we're going
to make it work for you and these are
our policies that we're going to do
right now to help you through this this
biggest cost of living crisis we've ever
faced cost of living crisis we've ever
faced you've clearly got ideas uh that
you want to see at Labor moving towards
are you tempted to come back to
Westminster and put them into action I
couldn't help but notice there's a
by-election coming off in West
Lancashire after Rosie Cooper and then
she's stepping down he tempted to throw
your hat in the ring
well I said I would do a full second
term in Greater Manchester and I'm in
the middle of that and to be honest with
you it's it's so energizing what we're
doing you know we're making change
happen here you know that decision to
put buses under public control that is
where my head is right now we are in the
middle of a massive performance between
transport
what about um what about in 2024 when
your term comes to an end
well my term is still going in 2024 so
you know as I say that's where my focus
uh my focus is I've be honest with you
Sophie I've said I've not ruled out
coming back uh one day but I've made
commitments to the people of Greater
Manchester I'm going to see those
commitments through
okay um
I'll read uh that you said you felt
imposter uh syndrome during a time at
Westminster before uh I just wonder if
you could you know I'm sure that's
something that lots of us including
myself can
um really relate to
um has that changed do you think you'd
make a good prime minister now
I think um people are kind of seeing the
real me more
um you do get that sense of feeling you
know do I really belong here when you're
in that Westminster system because of
the way it is
um I can't be the first person to have
to have felt some of that but also I
think the way it works isn't helpful for
connecting politics to people because it
it makes you vote in a way that you
might not necessarily fully believe in
because of the whip system or you have
to say things to take the line that the
party wants you to take and I think you
kind of get to a point where the public
will think well who is this person
because you know does he really believe
all of these things I think Westminster
does that it the risk is it makes a
fraud out of people because you're
always kind of doing things you half
believe in or you don't fully want to
say and I feel much more liberated and
clear out of Westminster about what I'm
about what I'm trying to do for the
people of Greater Manchester but the
bigger reforms I think the country makes
and I I've stopped sort of you know kind
of speaking in code if you like you know
I you I thought you thought I was
speaking in code at the start of this
interview but I wasn't uh you know I was
I say now what I think is is needed uh I
hope that's a helpful independent voice
if you like you know without all of the
kind of the the the the
um the strictures of Westminster holding
me back I just think it's it's
beneficial for politics to have people
like me in these mayoral positions we
can speak for people from The Real World
as you said uh at the start of the
interview and I think that's a helpful
blast of reality into into Westminster
at times which doesn't always uh operate
in that way
I've been told that I I need to run out
of time but I just want to squeeze in
one uh more a very quick one if I may um
Mr Burnham you know you were talking
there about the kind of experience
you've had as mayor do you think you
might make a better crack at the
leadership now than you did last time
when you obviously failed to win
well I I didn't just lose once uh Sophie
as you remember I lost twice so I didn't
make a very good good cracker at all did
I so um you know I as I say I've kind of
taken a step outside I think it's been
to to my uh to my benefit I wouldn't
rule out one day going back as I've said
I'm just just going to be honest about
that and I probably am a a better
politician I think anyway these these
days because as I say I'm not kind of
caveating everything I'm not sort of
second guessing everything I'm just
calling things as I see them and just if
I could say finally when it comes to the
government you know I don't play they
think I always play Party politics I
don't if the government gets something
right I will say so such as the help
they're giving us to reform buses that's
right thank you that's the right thing
to do but where they get things wrong I
will call things out as strongly as I
can and what they've just done as I say
again it's obscene it's a moral throwing
billions at the richest people in this
country at this moment in time it's a
recipe for I think serious serious
issues over this winter and that's why
the labor movement now needs to unite
and fight it okay understood thank you
very much Andy Burnham there talking to
us from labor conference